هم اتخذوا غير المنع
المادي للكتاب احنا اتخذوا كذلك سياسه
ماكره هي ان كثير من الكتاب الذين يؤالونه
قد كتبوا مقالات تشير الان الكتاب فارق
وليس في اي مضمون ولا محتوى سوى دفاع
مجرد عن الترابي وايدان على عثمان فشاه
شاه هذا المفهوم وسطهم وكان اكثر ما
يحرصون على حمايتهم اعضاء الحركه لا سيما
شبابها ولكن كثير منهم جاء الى القاهره
واشترى الكتاب وقراه وقابلني
سرا ونجوى وحدثني ان الكتاب احدى الصدمه
وسط شباب الحركه الذين كانوا يرون ان
قيادتهم هي قياده مقدسه لا تخطي ولكن
الكتاب هذه الشخصيات المقدسه الرفيعه قد
اعادها الى الارض وحولها الى شخصيات عاديه
دون العاديه تتامر
وتبزل مجهود كبير في المكائد وفي المكاسب
الشخصيه وكذلك تمارس الفساد وتمارس
التعذيب وكل هذا كان بمثابه صدمه للقاعده
الشفافيه للحركه طبعا غير اني تحدثت عن
مواضيع مهمه العلاقه بين الجيش والتنظيم
عن التحول في الحكم الاتحادي وتطوره ان
الاقتصاد الاقتصاد الانقاذ من الفلسفه الى
الفوضى فالكتاب كبير في 450 صفحه وفي فصول
كثيره وكان كنت احاول اكون موضوعيا جدا
واكثر ما اركز على الافكار ليس الاشخاص